filières d'excellence voie de garage
solution réaliste quand on est étudiant
à évoluer dans l'enseignement supérieur
est synonyme de casse tête voire
d'angoise avant c'était surtout à la
sortie du lycée qu'on souffre le plus
mais depuis que les masters applique une
sélection certains bac + 3 se retrouve
bloqué sans possibilité d'atteindre
leurs objectifs universitaire depuis
les étudiants qui ont décroché leur
licence sont désormais sélectionner à
l'entrée des masters le portail
trouve-t-on master point gouv.fr les
oriente vers des formations disponibles
si un étudiant et refuser de plusieurs
masters il a des recours à sa
disposition pour trouver une filière
plus en adéquation avec ses attentes
mais ces recours ont explosé en 2020
avec une hausse de 129% selon un rapport
du haut conseil de l'évaluation de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
sur twitter le hashtag étudiants son
master s'est retrouvé parmi les
tendances au top le 24 juin dernier est
maintenant de jeunes se plaignant de ne
rien trouver ou alors de trouver des
formations qui les intéressent peu
malgré des notes tout à fait correct
certaines filières comme le droit la
psychologie sont sur représentées parmi
ces profils une pétition en ligne signée
par plus de 2300 personnes dénoncent
cette angoisse ressentie par les
étudiants qui les poussera à multiplier
les candidatures pour des master de
moindre intérêt ce qui contribuerait à
maintenir l'embouteillage et à prendre
la place d'autres étudiants désireux
d'accéder à ces formations
je pense que le colis 2009 et là la
mauvaise gestion de près des rives idéal
aux fins de l'humanitaire est énorme
comme des explosions
tout le monde doit avoir droit à des
études de l'ucl et est aussi avoir un
avenir à monsieur se retrouver dans le
mauvais cursus un peu tout gâcher
certains on va tout dans la bonne
filière et donc à le rappeler leurs
études et avoir un métier qui ne leur
plaît pas quand dans certains masters
vous avez pour 25 places seulement plus
d'un millier de candidature comme à
créteil ou à clermont ferrand où on voit
bien que il ya clairement un désarroi
pour se les malheureux nouveaux
licenciés qui ne trouvent pas de master
pour poursuivre leurs études
il faut bien comprendre que que c'est
que cette affluence trop nombreuses de
trop importante de d'étudiants cette
sélection entre guillemets qui est un
peu un gros mot et bien en fait les
étudiants n'arrive pas vraiment à la
contrainte pas forcément parce qu'ils
sont contre cette notion de sélection
mais surtout parce que cette s'est refus
de master sont rudes injuste côté
gouvernement cet appel de détresse
semble être arrivée aux oreilles de la
ministre les années précédentes c'est
170 mille jeunes qui s'inscrivent en
master 1 et on avait entre 2000 et 3000
recours qui était gérée par les recteurs
donc c'est sur cette base là que nous
avons pris la décision de proposer aux
établissements de créer entre 3000 et
4000 places de master supplémentaires
avec les financements qui accompagnent
ces créations de places frédéric vidal a
par ailleurs annoncé que trouve-t-on
master point gouv.fr sera refondu sur le
modèle de parcours sup afin de donner
plus de visibilité aux formations
disponibles avec des délais de prise en
charge raccourci mais pour les
détracteurs de ce système ces décisions
ne sont pas en mesure d'éviter la
saturation de certaines filières l'idée
régler le problème de l'explosion des
demandes de recours
quant aux étudiants sans master certains
après un parcours du combattant
administratif arrive à décrocher une
formation
d'autres choisissent le privé s'ils en
ont les moyens ou encore ils décident de
s'expatrier pour finir leurs études
mais cette dernière solution est très
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre pandémie
de covile 19 oblige